hello everyone and welcome to a game
from the final round of the 2019
Sinquefield cup it's maxime beaugeois
gravitas and definitely a game that's
going to have a huge impact on the
standings and it's the first game that
finished it's not the first game to
finish the first game was a so versus
argument that game ended in a draw a
very quick draw
I think they drew in some 15 minutes but
this is the first game that ended that
will affect the the top of the standings
so without further ado let's check it
out and let's see what happens Maxime
has the white pieces and he opens with E
for Carlsen of course replies c5 to e4
as he studied that quite a lot for the
World Chess Championship match with
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and now will
we see a special cover not not this game
Bishop to b5 we have the news Medina of
eros SoLoMo we have g6 by crossing the
line he always goes for Bishop captures
B captures and now d4 expanding in the
center with C capture Sundy for Queen
captures on d4 attacking the rook and
now f6 this is definitely one of the
cases where it's okay to play f6 with
castles by Maxime and now d6
with c4 and grabbing more space in the
center and now c5 pushing the Queen back
Queen to d3 by magazine and now Bishop
to g7 and this position has already been
reached in the 2019 Tata Steel addition
between Vladislav Kovalev and the
pregnant Honda where b3 was played by
vladislav koalas
sorry Knight to c3 was played by quality
but here Maxime goes for b3 and now it's
a completely new game already as of move
10 across and continuous development
with Knight to h6 this night is coming
to f7 and from there to e5 or g5
depending on what white plays now Knight
to c3 with rook to b8 and now Bishop to
b2
there are also some ideas of night h4
followed by f4 but Maxime prefers the
line he obviously prepared
Bishop d2 not beat you with castles by
Magnus and now comes Luke
81 and sorry no idea why I picked up
that rock rook 81 with night to f7
magnets continiously maneuvering the
night over to e5 and now h4 Maxime wants
to push h5 and well do some damage
against the cross and skiing side we've
looked the b7 as this rook can now be
used as a defender of the Kings side
after this a pawn moves but also if for
example h5 is played in 4 if the G file
becomes semi open then the roofs can
also occupy the G file after the King
moves to h8 we have h5 by Maxine and now
of course g5 Magnus not interested in
opening up his King side but now Knight
- H - of course Maxime wants to bust
open the King said he wants to play f4
and will start the attack against cousin
schemed with night Stewie 5 now the
knight vacated DF 3 square this night
can come to e5 would an attack on the
Queen Queen to g3 and now King to h8 as
Crossan knows the G file will open up he
makes room for his rooks with f4 by
Maxine GK person f4 Bishop captures on
f4 and now rook the g8 and here rook to
e3 preparing a very nice rock lift and
also now the Queen can move as the rook
will also be guarding the knight on c3
you never know when this the the the
dragon will open up with Knight to c6
going after the d4 square now I'm much
more active Square and the Queen back to
f2 you could have also gone Bishop - h
h6 right away trying to trade opening up
a discovery against the Queen but Magnus
says there's time for that but this is
better with Queen to f2 and now
f5 now opening up at this bishops
diagonal and after this point is traded
this Bishop can come into the play as
well and here the best course for Maxime
is just captures captures and rook to g3
the game continues and well this would
be best but here Maxime played Knight to
f3 instead
this just doesn't work for a very
specific reason you are more than
welcome to pause the video here and try
to find why this doesn't work well I'll
give you a couple of seconds it's not an
easy idea so you know feel free to take
even more seconds but for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations
you have just found a very anti
positional move which is the winning
move in the position basically and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
Bishop captures on c3 it seems like a
very unnatural move giving your prize
the bishop your dragon for for this
knight on c3 but if it works it works
rook captures on c3 and now comes a five
and here comes a problem for white here
maxine has to figure out how to deal
with this bishop here problem is if you
move it let's say you go to h2 you get
f4 you open up this business diagonal
and now you see the problem white is
unable to do anything about this pawn
Center here and you're gonna play rook
rugby to g7 you're gonna go after the G
to pawn this bishop is coming to h3 the
queen is coming to f6 the g7 or maybe to
some to some other squares but it's
definitely gonna be very crowded in
front of the White King one such idea
can be king h1 you don't want to allow
Bishop to h3 then Ruby g7 I are gonna go
wrong g1 you have to defend the g2 pawn
Knight to d4 now rook to be three
Knights capture Sun f3g characters and
now rook captures in g1 with Czech
Bishop captures and the now Bishop to h3
check would have to check a rook to d2
and do not look the g3 the Queen can
outcome the g5 to h4 and it's gonna be
it's gonna be impossible to defend this
so that's one idea if you move the
bishop to h2 if you move it's the see if
you move it to h6 then black and just
kick it away with Queen to f6 again
you'd have to move back if you move the
bishop here still alive f4 the same
ideas now apply or Roby's coming here
Bishop is coming here and you don't have
your bishop here to help out with the
defense so this is even worse so here
after after a long thing Maxime finds
rook to d3 and now it's a very creative
defensive
source the ideas after this Bishop is
captured you want to play queen bee to
check and then push h6 because black
will have to block with the rook and
then you will attack the pin piece
basically you will win that rook at some
point but Magnus took some 22 minutes
here to calculate can he actually play
pawn captures Bishop and in the end he
decided to do it he played the pawn
captures Bishop with Queen to be 2 with
Czech roadblocks Ruby g7 and now h6 and
now of course Maxime will win material
back as now the rook is pinned and at
any point Maxime can just play H
captures on g7 with the Czech but Magnus
falls were calculated that he has F
captors on e4 and now Magnus will also
win more material we've looked the d2
and now e captures on f3 also possible
was queen t7 but this is such an odd
move to play especially when you can win
material right away at the idea is that
now even though white and play rookie to
now you cannot capture and do to the pin
but Bishop to g4 and after rook to e1
unpinning now III and after white makes
this capture as he will have to do it at
some point captures captures it's
actually crossing who's up material he
has a knight and the bishop for a rook
he has two excellent pawns here and the
black is just what is just lost here
there's not nothing to do here those
rooks are pretty much useless but it's
always better to grab piece if it works
so calls and grabbed a piece with it
captures on f3
now Maxine grab the rook gh captures on
g7 with Czech rook captures and g7 and
now rook captures on f3 with Queen to g5
now defending the f4 pawn also putting
pressure against the g2 pawn and now
rook D 2 F 2 if you try rook captures on
d6 then you get night to the d4 you
prevent the rook from coming back and
also your rook and g7 is no longer pin
so here you really have to just give up
your your look for a night otherwise
you're gonna play something like group 2
f2 but then you get Bishop to d7 and now
all of your pieces are going after
the g2 porn f3 is coming there's nothing
you can do about it you will have to
capture here and then after C captures
and Queen captures you're just up a
Bishop f3 is still coming so not much to
do there
so after Queen g5 with rook D - f - not
preparing to capture on f4 and khasinau
goes nice to be for an excellent
centralized square for the knight the
rook is no longer pinned as the doctrine
is no longer controlling this diagonal
but now Maxine gets the capture an f4
with rook captures on f4 and now Bishop
to f5 just not allowing any lucrative
check ideas sort of closing the position
with B for my magazine he has to play
something and now Bishop to e6 going
after the c4 pawn but also getting ready
to meet a rook to f8 check with Bush of
the g8 instead of rook the g8
we've looked at faith check Bishop the
g8 now the rook and Queen are still
putting a lot of pressure all along the
G file B captors on c5 with D captors
and c5 and here you could try rook to e8
maybe try and get the other rook over
there
but maxime tried Queen to be it instead
we have Queen to III by Magnus now
painting this rook here also good ideas
of nice D to check for example if you
play something like a 4 then nice the e
to check is very strong for example King
f1 you're gonna play queen c1 check
invite to the King to come into the
board and then a rookie 7 check and this
actually leads the mate king of three
you're gonna play Queen III check King G
for rogue g7 trick King of five Queen b6
check King to f4 you're gonna go rook g4
check and after.look f3 Queen to e4 will
be
mate so you don't want to allow Knight
to e2 check
Queen to d6 now the Queen will be able
to help out with the defense if such a
such a check of curse but here Magnus
plays Queen to c1 check instead and here
again if you play rook to f1 you're
gonna get night Stewie to check and
therefore King to have two Queen to be
to threatening a lot of nasty
discoveries
so after the king goes up the board
you're gonna go nice to see one and here
there are just too many threats Queen
here is a threat Queen here check is a
threat you can bring the rook over if
the if the White Queen moves you can go
look to GT Richard so the King and III
would there are too many dangers to
survive this
so after Queen to see one check Maxime
played King to h2 and now Queen back to
g5 keeping an eye on that g7 square and
this diagonal and also you don't want to
allow ideas like rook captures Bishop
and then after rook captures or you get
made it after real captures you're gonna
allow some sort of a perpetual with
Queen f6 to DA so Queen to g5 and here
the best idea for why it seems to be g3
but it's such a weird move to play
weakening your Kings position even
further then you get g6 with an attack
on the Queen
you can play rook to h6 later and after
Queen to f4 Queen to e7 again just
avoiding trades Queen to h4 offering a
trade now Queen to d6
again putting pressure against this pawn
here and now finally after rook to f6
you will be able to trade rook captures
Queen captures Queen captures rook
captures but now you get Bishop captures
on c4 and you can maybe hope to somehow
survive this endgame with rook against
the knight and Bishop being down upon
which is very unlikely especially
against a world champion
so after Queen to g5 we have Queen to d5
Maxine tries to trade Queens but now
without the g3 point eh Foursquare is
available for call since Queen we have
Queen to h4 check King to g1 and now
Queen to e7 preparing Queen to a1 this
will now come with check and here
maxime played Queen to h5 which is very
interesting as there was a very
interesting line for example let's say
some weird moves played like a four
Carson's idea behind the Queen to e1 and
involved a lot of a lot of dangers
because here Queen to e1 isn't the most
precise way to go here you could get
King to h2 and now the whole point
Queen captures on f2 and now you're
hoping for rook captures this would
unpin the bishop and then you would just
eliminate whites Queen the problem is
here you again face rook captures on g8
and after rook captures on g8 now you
have to capture with the rook as the
Queen is guarding after this rook
captures nga - Queen B five check
ensures a perpetual and it's a draw
Luke g7 you're just gonna go Queen b8
rogue g8 Queen to e5 you cannot block
with the Queen the f6 square is
unguarded so here would be a good
opportunity to you know grab a draw yeah
but it wouldn't work either way now
because he black could just play rook to
g6 instead bring the King over to g7 and
then continue winning the game now but
okay Maxime played Queen to h5 instead
but now comes Queen to III again
freezing the position a bit you cannot
move the rook here Queen to Knight to e2
again a threat if the Queen ever moves
from guarding the e2 square you you're
going to have threats of Ruby g5 you can
go rule g6 to h6 the Queen are also
guards the h6 square so a lot of ideas
here and it's very hard for Maxime to
make a move Queen D 1 maybe 2 D 2 it
would be - way to go Maxime try the
Queen to h4 but now he allows what was
in the position all this time so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea for Magnus in this
position well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those we were able to do
it congratulations you have just maybe
one the Sinquefield Cup for the second
time in your life and for those of you
who want to enjoy the show
Knight to e2 check and now whatever you
play King h1 or f1 for example if F 1
then it's it's a knight g3 check and
after King back to g1 Queen e1 check now
you have to block let's say Brooke f1
night e to check King h1 and now just
Queen captures on h4 will be mate that's
one way to do it of course after this
check Maxime played came to h1 but now
comes Queen 2 c1
and again if you bring the king of the
board here again getting made at Queen G
to check English to read Queen h1 check
is mate
and after Queen to c1 check rook to f1
which was played in the game now comes
Knight g3 check and now you get Kim Ji
Won Quinta III check and it was in this
position and move 44 that Maxim for
sherrilyn Grove resigned the game and a
very nice well deserved victory for
Magnus Carlsen in the final round of the
sinful cup he resigned because now you
have to play something for example if
you move the King King eh - just Knight
captures with check and after rook
captures you get rook to g6 for example
hoping to win the Queen here but
whatever white place doesn't really
matter if rook f3
we need 5 check Quinta 4 and now you can
go Queen to g7 attacking the g2 pawn
let's say the pawn moves now you get to
rob g4 and now you can deliver something
deadly checks for example or you can
just win the c4 pawn and basically
Carson his upper piece and the White has
no counter play so here he resigned the
game even though maxime had I believe he
had like an hour more on the clock than
Magnus Magnus had 20 something minutes
I'm seeing was over an hour on the clock
but still he played that weird Moon
Knight of 3 which a lot caused him to
give up his dragon for this a very nice
attack and that was that was it but a
very resource a resourceful defense rook
to d3 by Maxine
it almost worked but it didn't so that's
it it's hard to say how this affects the
standings at the moment the game ended
while I was recording this video Carlson
had a clear first place but still our
players have to finish their games dink
is still playing against Muhammad er of
net boys playing a good game a lot of a
lot of them have chances so it's hard to
say if ding draws I believe tomorrow
there will be a playoff it's not gonna
be like last year where you had three
winners were crossing corona and Ariane
shared first place but if Magnus manages
to win this it will be his second time
to win the sinful cup the first time was
in 2013 and last year he like I said
he got shared first so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Jonathan Willis Jarvis Paul guest
and Steve Kimmons for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with at
least one more game from a single Cup as
we do have to check out the standings
and maybe even with a playoff a few
playoff games tomorrow and of course
continue the capablanca saga and
checking up on your suggestions I think
y'all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day